John Keating, Actor/Brian Cutler Assistant
Camera Operator: We are rolling we have speed,
we have a mark, action!
Rachel Highbrou, Actor: The doctor said
we could stay here in the chapel and talk.
Khigh Abner, Actor: Okay, sure.
What are we going to do?
I don't know it's not fair none of it.
That poor little thing
You know it has a heart is beating right
how can that be how could it have such a
tiny healthy heart that everything else be so
maybe it's not for us to understand we
understand well enough it is what it is
it's got multiple birth defects that's what
the doctor said please don't call her it
she has a name Melanie she's a human being she's
alive she belongs to you and to me that's not true
she does belong to me nor do you either
she is no part of us what do you think
those doctors can do with surgery make
her a whole person from a sort of parts
you're mistaken even think
that they can't do a damn thing
The doctor said a decision must be made now
oh God oh God Is Right you're the one who believes
in all that crap so tell me what does your God
tell you to do now to keep her alive and to take
care of her forever it's been seven days today
it's appropriate to me that on
the seventh day your God rested so
today is resting where going fishing
out to lunch be back in an hour
but you get the bastard back here because I want
to talk to him now don't don't talk like that
I think God's fault whose fault is it
it's not for us to understand whose fault is it my
yours it isn't anybody's fault I don't accept that
please you know maybe maybe we shouldn't have used
birth control pills maybe you shouldn't have
experimented drugs back in your college days
you heard me are you blaming me are
you saying that this is my fault
you did drugs too back then maybe it's
your fault I need to know why I'm baby
I was born like this it's
God's will we must accept that
she's a special baby there are
special schools oh no no no no
stink you know what honest to
Christ they gave us the wrong one
can't deal with this
serious
I cannot handle this for the rest of my life
you know what I refuse to be responsible
for the saying nobody can make me
but Melanie is our responsibility.
She's all we have and we're going to tell the
doctor to do the operation to do everything in
his power to give her the best possible chance in
this world serious what chances I have just what
no no no we are not going to we have to no we
don't have to and we won't it's not fair to
her shouldn't asked to be born we wanted her and
we're going to tell the doctor to do everything
that he can I love her and I don't care what you
say she has just as much a right to live as you do
and we're going to tell him to do what
he can no we won't because if I have to
I'll stop her living myself and damn
you no you won't couldn't do that
God will give us the strength no shut up shut up
I've heard all I want to hear about your
absentee God it does not exist speak
please please please please please let us help her
all right wait all right it'll it'll
be all right okay I promise you
promise it'll be all right okay just we we all
right we will talk to the doctor again okay
let's please please please don't don't cry anymore
Brian Cutler, Teacher:
And cut!
that's all right
nice work okay yeah yeah you have a slow roll
Slow Burn okay you know but that's okay if
that's the way you felt like doing it that's
the way you do it you know Jack Nicholson says
if you get a feeling go with it you know if
it's not right that the Articles they take do
pretty simple you know pretty simple everything
we're doing here is simple guys you're just not
easy you know this process is simple simple simple
simple simple lovely work good for both of you
thank you okay ready to do it again yeah change
it up it's up to you change it up I don't want
to give you a redirect because there's no reason
to if there is something that wasn't working I'd
tell you but it's working so if it ain't broke
don't fix it you know let go a little more be
a little Freer with her you know I feel you
hold them back a little bit don't hold back
all right
we're rolling sound is speeding we
have a mark whenever you're ready
the doctor said we go stay in the chapel and talk
okay sure
what are we going to do
I don't know it's not fair is it a poor little
thing it has a heart it's beating I mean how
can that be how can it have such a tiny
healthy heart and everything else be so just
maybe it's not for us to understand
we understand it well enough
it is what it is it's got multiple birth
defects that's what the doctor said
please don't call her eight she has a name Melanie
she's a human being she's alive and she belongs to
you and me that's not true she doesn't belong
to me what are you either part of us what do
you think those doctors can do with surgery
make her a whole person from assorted parts
didn't mistake it if you think
that they can't do a damn thing
well they said a decision must be made now
okay oh God Is Right you believe in all that crap
what does your God tell you to do now to
keep her alive and to take care of her
in seven days today it seems appropriate
to me that on the seven day your God rested
so today is resting resting where going fishing
out to lunch back an hour is that what he's
doing well you get the basket back here right
now because I want to talk to him right now
don't don't talk like that this is
not God's fault whose fault is it
maybe we don't understand no no
whose fault is it tell me mine
yours what this isn't anybody's
fault I do not accept that please
all right maybe maybe we we shouldn't have used
birth control pills no maybe you shouldn't have
done all the experimentation with drugs
during your college days what you heard
me are you blaming me are you saying that this
is my fault you took drugs too back then maybe
it's your fault no I need to know right now
why our baby is born like this it's God's will
so well what you're going to tell me now we
will grow up and we'll take you to some kind
of well those special schools or something
like that no no no I don't want to hear it
is all a mistake it's just a big mistake
honestly Christ you know they just gave
us the wrong one that's what it is
I can't deal with this I'm serious
I can't handle this for the rest of my life you
know what I refuse to be responsible for this
nobody can make me but we are responsible for
Melanie we are all she has and we're going to
tell the doctor to do the operation we're going
to tell him to do everything in his power to give
her the best possible chances chance for
what what chance does it have no no no no
we're not going to we have to no we don't have
to and we're not going to it's not fair to it
she didn't ask to be born we wanted her I love
her and I don't care what you say she has as
much a right to live as you do so we're going
to tell him to do whatever he can no we won't
and if I have to I will stop reliving myself
damn you no you won't I didn't do that
God will give us the strength no no no I've
heard all I want to hear about your absentee God
exist stop it
stop it God is that special little baby
God is you and me and our little girl
please just let them help her
all right it'll be all right
it'll be all right we'll we'll go ahead
we'll talk to the doctors now okay
please right or okay we'll be all right
all right we'll talk to dogs again
good good good stay up there guy you're going
to do it again oh okay got another one in you
so yeah yeah good good light
nice for y'all good for you